the land of ice is fast becoming the
land of opportunity
global warming is melting Greenland
exposing the rocks beneath and
attracting speculators but president
Trump's interest in buying the country
had been dismissed as a joke not anymore
essentially it's a large real estate
deal a lot of things could be done it's
hurting Denmark very badly because
they're losing almost 700 million
dollars here carrying it so they carry
it at a great loss and strategically for
the United States it would be nice
that's bemused Greenlanders and the
Danes who were responsible for the
country's foreign and defense policy
Denmark's prime minister who's visiting
Greenland said president Trump's offer
was absurd thankfully the time where you
buy and sell other countries and
populations is over let's leave it there
jokes aside we would naturally love to
have an even closer strategic
relationship with the u.s. beneath this
vast ice cap Greenland is thought to
have large deposits of zinc copper gold
and uranium
the Chinese already have a stake in a
company mining the country's mineral
wealth these trees growing in the
southern part of Greenland for the first
time in several thousand years so this
is an area that is opening up
essentially this is the frontier in
terms of mineral exploration and
exploitation and there is a giant tug of
war going on in that frontier between
China and the US the bizarre episode has
at least put Greenland on the map and a
tourist authorities sense an opportunity
Greenland is not the same but open for
business
being from visit Greenland who are
trying to get more tourists we will try
to turn this attention towards the
Greenland for something positive the
Arctic is warming twice as fast as
anywhere else on the planet Russia is
already building up its military
presence to protect its claim for oil
and shipping routes in the far north
ice has little value but the
and see beneath could bring riches
Thomas more Sky News